imagine if all the Earth's oxygen
disappeared
not forever just for say an hour
could you hold your breath that long
what would happen to the atmosphere and
could the Earth ever recover from this
planet-wide suffocation
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the world lost oxygen for an
hour
take a nice deep breath
feel how satisfying that is nice what
you're breathing in is oxygen and it
takes up roughly 21 of our atmosphere
it's not the most abundant gas in our
atmosphere way to Breathe No breath but
it is the most important
plants animals water and US humans
wouldn't be where we are today without
oxygen
but now you're saying goodbye to that
sweet sweet breathable air for an entire
hour and spoilers
[Music]
the world record for the longest held
breath clocks in at 24 minutes and 37
seconds not bad but that doesn't do you
much good considering the average person
can hold their breath from 30 to 90
seconds tops
whoa brace yourself This is Gonna Hurt
if the world suddenly lost oxygen for a
whole hour the rapid decrease in
pressure would painfully blow out your
inner ear
how much pressure well think of standing
on top of Mount Everest
only instantly
this would leave you stumbling for
balance as you suffocate oh did I not
mention the Suffocation yeah as you
struggle to catch your breath your heart
would start beating in overdrive
this is a problem seeing as how your
heart and lungs need oxygen to function
when that's off the table you can expect
excruciating chest pains
after six minutes max your brain would
be out of oxygen which means well you'd
be dead
sucks right well it gets even worse
you see an average person weighing 80
kilograms consists of 52 kilograms of
oxygen with oxygen gone for the entire
hour 65 of your body would just go poof
yeah I'm talking Thanos snap
disintegration poof
so much for the human race but how would
the rest of the planet fare
well in just one hour the Earth would
look completely different
without oxygen you can say goodbye to
the Hoover Dam the pantheon Dome and
anything else made of concrete
these structures would instantly
collapse
oxygen acts as a special binding agent
to concrete without it concrete is just
dust so of buildings any untreated metal
would be instantly fused
there's a layer of oxidation on metals
that prevents them from welding together
without that layer Metals would
immediately bind to each other and
that's just a ground level it's getting
a whole lot worse up top
the ozone layer our protection against
the Sun's UV rays is made up of oxygen
atoms that have bonded to create ozone
take away the oxygen and the Earth would
get extremely hot
there would be nothing to protect us
from the Sun's UV rays having a good
time yet well don't expect it to last
too long without oxygen there's no fire
the combustion process in vehicles
wouldn't happen
any mode of Transport that isn't
electric would automatically fail
planes would fall from the sky and
millions of cars would be left eroded
and abandoned
the sky would be completely dark
light from the sun bounces off multiple
particles in the air before it hits the
Earth
without oxygen in the atmosphere there
are fewer things to bounce off and the
sky would appear dark almost black
oh yeah and while all this is happening
the Earth's crust would completely
crumble
that's because the Earth's crust is 45
oxygen the crust would crumble and
continue to crumble until there's
nothing left
sending the planet into a free fall
and that's our time the hour is over and
the oxygen is Flowing freely again
too bad you won't get to breathe it in
what with the planet being destroyed and
all human life disintegrated
but would New Life emerge From the Ashes
well if it did I hope they have stronger
lungs than we did luckily you can take a
deep breath of 21 oxygen knowing this
will never happen
wow I've never missed breathing so bad
and you know I could use some more
what if oxygen doubled in Earth's
atmosphere
well that's a story for another
[Music]